à 32 ans erica grappin est en contrat
unique d'insertion au collège ariane de
guyancourt après deux mois de chômage
elle a accepté une proposition de pôle
emploi agent polyvalent au service
général et à la restauration scolaire
pour ce contrat aidé de 30 heures par
semaine sur un an
erika gagnent un revenu de 880 euros par
mois en complément du rsa je vais
chercher mon chariot je pars dans mes
classes je fais les tableaux je lave les
tables ce qui a souvent des écritures ou
de la colle
après je passe un coup sur le sol
après j'aimerais bien pouvoir rester
dans un établissement scolaire parce
qu'en fait c'est quelque chose qui me
plaît
travailler dans un établissement
scolaire qui fait partie du département
ou de la région ou même des mairies et
tout le département embauché 258
bénéficiaires du rsa en contrats aidés
dans les collèges yvelinois depuis la
rentrée 2016 l'état le département et
pôle emploi collaborent sur ce
dispositif à travers le financement et
la formation par exemple sur ses 258
contrat il y à déjà 65 personnes qui
sont en formation hygiène qui leur
donnera des d un savoir faire
particulier au delà de ce contrat l'idée
ce n'est pas de transformer tous les
bénéficiaires du rsa en futurs agents de
la fonction publique
l'idée c'est de les mettre dans un
parcours d'employabilité
l'idée c'est de travailler au plus près
avec pôle emploi pour les pour les
compétences de départ et la capacité de
formation pour qu'ils aient un avenir
professionnel de dans ou en dehors de la
collectivité locale au 30 octobre 2016
le département comptabilise 24000 250
bénéficiaires du rsa 35 % ont entre 25
et 34 ans